please welcome patricia arquette
[Applause]
[Applause]
the beautiful girl okay i remember you
driving through west hollywood with your
son in the back seat in his car seat in
a suzuki samurai that's right people
okay and you looked so cool oh
and you're like open air
that was my first car i bought myself
and i used to see you driving around and
every time i saw you i was like there
she is
and i if it's okay um could i play what
is one of my favorite games here on this
show with you yes play it all right
everybody we're gonna play with patricia
arquette behind the scenes
[Applause]
all right
true romance
yes okay behind the scenes
here's a crazy story so
tony scott our director i came in with
these like hair like that right he's
like i do not like that hair i was like
but i really want to have this hair and
he was like
okay why are you doing that hair and i
was like well i think she grew up
watching for a faucet and she doesn't
know how to do feathered hair but this
is her like version of feathered hair
he's like you got it
we're wearing the rolls okay good let's
go that is the best fly on the wall
thank gosh for tony scott going with
your artistic vision
it pays off in dividends
beautiful
okay
medium
medium
working on this show we have to do it's
like 16 hour days
i can't tell you how many times they
were like an action
and i'm like
they're like patricia wake up
okay
so i actually fall asleep all the time i
was falling asleep all the time when i'm
supposed to wake up there are times
where i'm really waking up
that is so great i love that and by the
way
good acting because it's real thank you
exactly exactly
okay boyhood just boyhood that's a
boyfriend
boy had another amazing experience
richard link letter this whole crew we
showed up every year it's miraculous
that movie ever got financing because we
could have just in year eight said like
give me a lot more money i'm not coming
back whatever
so when you're winning the oscar
for that film are you like oh
not that the experience wasn't enough
but what's going through your mind
because your speech made headlines and
was magnanimous about equal pay for
women
um
yeah
well
when i when i was getting there i was
like wait
why am i winning this if i'm gonna win
this why am i winning this oh because i
played a mom who was the primary
caretaker for her kids
how would her life have been different
had she earned her full dollar
and been able to take care of her kids
how would their lives have been
different so if this hap moment is going
to happen that i didn't try to force to
happen
then i'm going to use this to be
do something good for everybody so i
just went up there and was like okay
here we go
you know
equal pay and equal rights well it
really made waves around the world for
all the right reasons thank you
i'm gonna go into next the act
oh my god
yeah scary yeah spooky
that's kind of the worst nightmare
right
and my kids already knew of the story i
was like hey i got offered this script
you guys it's about um dd and gypsy
blanchard don't do it please don't do it
don't do it mom don't do it i'm like you
guys i'm not going to become her
you know me please don't do it she's so
scary she's so scary
yeah yeah okay this one um is honestly
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's um
a beautiful uh independent film directed
by sean penn it's called the indian
runner
[Applause]
when i saw this film
i thought it was one of the most
beautiful performances i've ever seen
from any actress who ever lived oh
thank you and there's a moment when
viggo mortensen i think he spits on you
yeah
and your cry your reaction
well thank you
oh it was really intense vigo was great
and sean was great vigo of course felt
bad you know doing this scene but i was
like no no no let's do this seat
um
let's really go for it and tell the
truth
of these moments you know that are
shocking and
totally disarming
if you're with somebody you love and
they
have impulse control issues and go off
on you and then
how do you deal with the ramification of
that kind of
storm it is so amazing to hear your
process i feel like i'm getting an
inside the actor's studio like oh you're
just fantasy like i'm living in the
center of it like i'm actually like i i
am the fly on the wall
[Music]